hey leute was knapp und herzlich
willkommen beim neuen video tv anfangen
wollt ihr euch einen special guest
vorstellen der heute dabei ist und zwar
ja und da ich ein bisschen unzufrieden
mit meinen haaren bin heute ich hab noch
nicht gelöscht habe ich echt noch nicht
habe ich wieder so ein hässliches
teilung wir wollen aber auch gar nicht
lange lagern und zwar gestern im video
schon gesagt ja heute kommt eventuell
was mit meiner wundervollen hübschen
meine freundin genau mit meiner mit
meinen freunden und zurzeit das kommt ja
aus dem amerikanischen raum das wird
jetzt auch nach deutschland viele
deutsche youtuber machen dass keine
ahnung wer alles ist mir jetzt auch egal
ich hoffe ich muss jetzt nicht wieder
danke sagen an denen denen er das nach
deutschland geholt hat weil es wurde in
amerika von und zwar auf jeden fall gibt
es ja dieses musical das haben wir jetzt
auch gemacht vielleicht können wir
gleich einmal kurz musical von uns
angucken und darauf reagieren eigentlich
eigentlich ist es komplett bescheuert
und ich verstehe nicht warum das so
viele menschen toll finden und unsere
musici sind eigentlich ganz okay aber es
gibt ja auch so kinder oder so
zwölfjährige oder irgendwelche menschen
die einfach komplett dritte denkt sich
zeigt dass gleich ich habe gestern mich
schlau gemacht und da dachte ich echt
ach du scheiße
ja wir fangen mit diesem video wenn es
euch gefällt dann gefällt oder ich also
erstmal zum reinkommen unser musical i
damit ihr seht was da so abgeht so und
einen kleinen vergleich habt wie gut wir
eigentlich sind
137000 likes für diesen scheiß ehrlich
keine ahnung warum aber das ist echt gut
angekommen und mir jetzt zeigen wir euch
mal oder wir gucken jetzt was ob du
meinst du wirst es nicht lustig finde
was taugen
das sind irgendwelche musicals konnten
von irgendwelchen komischen menschen
weil er sieben war
was sollte schon den text können radio
es war ich das richtig lächerlich und
dabei sein herz immer nur so eine hälfte
machen kann warum die andere hälfte
kommt ja dazu weil besucher mit englisch
aber da kommt doch aus sorge vor
kennst du das wenn man sich so
fremdschämt dass man so gänsehaut
bekommt
sie denke so scheiße ich muss um mein
gott sagen das schreibe ich ja besser
aus
dieser mann vor dem risiko of screen ex
der heißt grill xscale ex naja leute das
waren jetzt ein paar musicals auf die
wir reactor oder wie das heißt wenn es
euch gefallen du hast gerne mal daumen
nach oben da wenn ihr sowas nochmal
sehen wollt dann sehen wir das jahr
beziehungsweise ich mache das dann
bestimmt noch mal ich sag mal bei 15.000
likes gute kommt davon auch ein zweiter
teil an sonst wenig sagen wie gesagt
jetzt kommen wieder viele videos morgen
jetzt bestimmt doch schon weiter wer
weiß 1809 keine ahnung
ja aber nicht vergessen damit über
passen unser musical a klasse mehr video
beschreibung könnt ihr mal vorbeischauen
bis sagen wir zuletzt zu sein
na ja dann würde ich sagen das war's mit
dem video
wir sehen uns morgen habe ich ja schon
zehn mal gesagt ungefähr 1 5 instagram
und dann bin ich zufrieden